wenn ich ihn jetzt 1000 euro anbieten
würde dass wir direkt nach münchen
fahren sollen auch schon recht naja gut
bei 1000 hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es
gut
okay sein eigentlich eher spontanes
video ich habe mir nämlich eigentlich
gesagt heute kommen wir nur videos auf
meinem zweikanal den ich euch ganz oben
in der video beschreibung verlinkt habt
schickt und auf jeden fall ab abonniert
den da kommen jeden tag drei videos
würde ich mich darüber freuen wenn ihr
das tut und blogger aktivieren und so
nur das übliche auf jeden fall habe ich
mir eben noch mal ein video von mir
angeschaut
ich lege mich jetzt mal kurz hin in dem
video ging es um das land vor letztes
video da ging es darum genau dasselbe
kaufen wie die person vor mir im saturn
also das war dieser fernsehen davon gibt
es auf jeden fall noch weitere paten
nächste woche oder vielleicht sogar
schon diese woche ich weiß nicht wo dann
auch das gewinnspiel dazu aufgelöst wird
also in dem video behält den fernseher
gewonnen hat unter dem video stand und
selbst viele kommentare was ich noch
machen kann und dieser kommentar ist
ganz besonders aufgefallen ohne dass ich
den überhaupt gelesen habt hatte der
schon über 1000 likes oder so und ich
finde die idee gar nicht mal so schlecht
nur mein bedenken ist halt wir sind hier
nicht bei den frank gross oder wenn das
you sondern auf meinem kanal und ich
krieg das nicht also wenn die post jetzt
mal als beispiel das machen würden
würden die wahrscheinlich in afrika
doch hier vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben aber ihr wisst glaube ich
was ich meine ja meine bedenken ist dass
wir halt jetzt gleich ins taxi steigen
und da hab ich irgendwo hinfährt und das
war's also ich kann euch keine garantie
dafür geben dass dieses video wirklich
krass wird trotzdem gehe ich ja mal sehr
gerne auf eure ideen ein und deswegen
machen wir das heute ich lebe noch mal
kurz den kommentar vor steigt in ein
taxi ein und sagt dem taxifahrer du
willst dorthin oder letzte gast
eingestiegen ist ja dass also natürlich
ist das interessant ist könnte
interessant werden ich will eigentlich
gar nicht eingeladen was ich noch sagen
wollte also ich hoffe dass das taxi das
kommt dann ja an dem erzähle ich dann
irgendwie dass sich das für ein uni
projekt brauche weil
ich weiß nicht ob das immer so eine
sache mit datenschutz und so ob man das
überhaupt machen darf keine ahnung und
dann ist das jetzt einfach so ein
kleiner block und wir schauen wir wo wir
am ende landen werden ich musste
natürlich auch irgendwie wieder
zurückkommen und ich bin werde ich mal
gespannt und ich weiß gar nicht ob es
klappt aber ihr kennt mich in letzter
zeit bin ich immer für so blöde ideen zu
haben deswegen machen wir das und das
feiert das jetzt wenn man doch nach oben
da schreibt noch weitere lustige
diejenigen kommentare und wir stellen
uns erst mal wenn ihr mal ab und zu in
fremde städte fahren dort taxifahrt holt
euch mytaxi ist eine super app die
benutze ich auch über das ist kein
placement oder so ich kann jetzt genau
meinen meine adresse eingeben
und jetzt wird das wir gesucht und dann
habe ich hoffentlich gleich ein fahrer
freut sich bestimmt schon auf mich
normalerweise geht das ein bisschen
schneller
der kommt mercedes benz e klasse ganz
entspannt da freue ich mich drauf elf
minuten dauert es acht
naja gut kann ich mich noch ein bisschen
ausruhen bevor es auf große reise geht
hier könnt ihr sehen elf minuten fahrer
unterwegs war gucken was jetzt in meinem
plan sagt und ja krass wäre natürlich
wenn es wirklich irgendwie schon ein
stückchen geld irgendwohin wo ich selber
noch nie war ich weiß nicht ich will gar
nicht so viel spekulieren
die nervosität steigt auf jeden fall
okay leute es sind bloss noch vier
minuten langsamer ich schon was wir
passieren ich habe mir hier noch ein
rucksack aufgesetzt damit ich so naja so
professionell professionell wirke ich
bin wirklich sehr gespannt was er sagen
wird oder ob er überhaupt irgendwas
sagen wird gleich eine sache noch in
einem kommentar standort dass ich da
hinfahren soll der letzte eingestiegen
ist viel mehr sinn willst da macht man
nicht dahin fahren würde wohl der letzte
ausgestiegen ist oder ok ich glaube der
star taxi leute genau vor unserer tür
ist halt mega stau er braucht jetzt noch
ein bisschen
ich könnte eigentlich schon mal
rausgehen okay leute erst da
danke schön einmal verrückt
wir haben von der uni so ein projekt da
geht's um taxierung also wundern sie
nicht darüber ich muss jetzt ein
bisschen dokumentieren wäre das möglich
dass sie mich einfach irgendwo hinfahren
wo der letzte fahrgast eingestiegen ist
oder ausgestiegen ist geht das okay das
wäre es auch schon
wir müssen das so ein bisschen hört sich
komisch
also heißt so von der also wo hast du
die meisten taxen lockern
denn genau leute ganz kurz zum
verständnis ich habe mich echt sehr sehr
sehr lange mit ihm unterhalten und wir
haben auch ein interessantes gespräch
geführt also ich fand es sehr
interessant
jetzt geht es halt darum warum ich
eigentlich mit ihm dorthin fahre wo ich
hinfahren möchte oder warum ich dort
hinfahren möchte wo die person vor
hingefahren ist weil der hat das
überhaupt nicht verstanden und ich
wusste auch irgendwann nicht mehr was
ich sagen sollte dann hab ich einmal
regen was gesagt und das glaube ich
nicht 14 gemacht und jeder muss heute
vom fahrt machen dann müssen wir das so
ich bin halbtags und dann sehen sie die
klassischen sachen gesagt wer zum 13
also touristen würden sie sagen da bin
ich eher weniger
maximal 56 wenn es das überhaupt
[Musik]
gibt es nur noch manchmal fahrten die
aus köln extrem rausgehen das ist
einfach nur schön weil das ist er jetzt
zu weit
wenn ich ihn jetzt 1000 euro anbieten
würde dass wir direkt nach
naja was war denn ihre links zu fahren
frage ja ich war ein paar mal den fragen
vor dem flughafen nach frankfurt okay
dann ist das 300 euro
dann würde ich das auch machen und das
passiert dann wahrscheinlich weil die
deutsche bahn gleis print oder was ist
dann der grund für so jemanden der das
sonim taxen macht weil ich meinen man
könnte ja auch bequemlichkeit zu viel
geld viel geld
ich habe irgendwelche leute aus dubai
wir haben natürlich doch
die wanderer mit dickem kopf
von bahnhof zu bahnhof zu tilgen
[Musik]
der ganze strand 20 prozent trinkgeld
vielen dank und sagte mir dann bedanke
ich mich für die angenehme fragt ja
wegen unserer mich ja genau hier bin ich
jetzt gelandet
ja ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung wo
wir sind
also ich weiß doch nie dahin ist ein
kindergarten oder so er hat ihr erzählt
dass ist industriegebiet und ich denke
mal da dachte sonst was von mir also
vielleicht war das auch ein bisschen
unüberlegter dem projekt weil es
irgendwie total unlogisch ist habt ihr
wahrscheinlich am gespräch auch
mitbekommen aber kann er mir jetzt auch
egal da ich mein ich bin da und was ich
aber sagen muss er war super sympathisch
also war eine richtig angenehme fahrt
und ich habe auch einiges gelernt über
weite strecken und was sinn macht und
was nicht gemacht ich glaube ein paar
sachen hab ich davon sicherlich auch
reingeschnitten jetzt ist halt nur die
frage wie komme ich von hier wieder nach
hause
2 wir sind so 8 kilometer weit weg weiß
sie dass ihr kennt da ganz hinten und
man ist der telekom turm und ungefähr da
muss ich hin
ungefähr so was geht du lustige frage
kannst du mich wenn ich den standort
hier kurz abholen also es ist echt ein
stückchen aber wenn mega korrekt also
ich würde mal sagen fährst du 20 minuten
oder so haas' nähe alles gut dann schaue
ich das sehen wir anders wegkomme mich
kann niemand abholen
ich lade jetzt zu fuß bis zur nächsten
bahn haltestelle ist ein zwei kilometer
um die ecke ist eine bahnstation aber
das ist halt nicht nur eine linie also
die kann ich eigentlich so gut wie
vergessen aber ich meine wir ein schönes
wetter bis in die natur genießen das
auch nicht schlecht ich bin jetzt schon
über zwei kilometer gelaufen ist bin ich
da ja nicht mal da dann bin ich gleich
zu hause also ich würde sagen wir sehen
uns zu hause wieder ein kleines ende
bis gleich nach gefühlten zehn jahren
eigentlich wieder zurück abschließen
würde ich sagen es war ganz lustig ich
bin jetzt 28 euro ärmer und es gibt
einen taxifahrer mehr auf der welt der
sich denkt wie komisch sind die menschen
ein will ich hoffe natürlich sehr dass
wieder durchgefallen lasst mir nach oben
dann sehe ich das ja erst mein zweiter
kanal harmonierten in der video
schreiben auf instagram heißt alex wie
schreibt weitere coole ideen in die
kommentare
ich freue mich erst mal aus zu trennen
ciao